بكتيريا اكله للحوم البشر كادت توتي بحياه
ام بريطانيه بعد انجابها مولودتها في
الثاني والعشرين من ابرول الماضي فما الذي
حدث معها تشارلي 27 عاما نقلت على نحو طار
الى المستشفى بعد اصابتها بطفح جلديا على
البطن وسخونه شديده للغايه مع اعراض
انفلونزا بعد سته ايام من الولاده واثر
الفحوصات شخص الاطباء مرضها بالتهاب
اللفافه النخر وحذر عائلتها من انها قتلها
تنجو وعلى وجه السرعه اجريت لها جراحه
لاستئصال عدد كبير من الانسجه الميته لمنع
انتشار البكتيريا التي كانت تتهم اللحم
فالتهاب اللفافه الناخر هو مرض غير شائع
تدخل خلاله البكتيريا القاتله للجزم عبر
الجروح او الخدوش او لدغه حشره لكن
الاصابه به قد تؤدي الى تهديد حياه شخص
اذا لم يخضع لعلاج سريع كما حصل
معاشاترتون التي غادرت المستشفى بعد
اسبوعين وعادت الى طفلتها السالمه